to those who have a message from the
people of sindh share your food in our
hour of need or we will take it from you
[Music]
the rich feel their stomachs and give us
the run around they make the children
chase food until they're out of breath
they've looted trucks before not by
choice but necessity
the newly homeless live on roadsides
with a view of their submerged houses
swarming passing cars for help they say
they are treated like dogs
we're going to set ourselves on fire
here if we don't eat then for sure we
will burn ourselves
the people who come to us for votes
during the election are ignoring us now
flood survivors sheltering in a vacant
building without services and threatened
with eviction say
pakistan's leaders are only interested
in photo opportunities
come to my house i'll show you how bad
it is the water's this high the walls
have fallen down where should we go we
came here and there's nothing
these are all pakistan people's party
voters the ppp wins in sindh where are
they now
a member of sin's assembly promised
things would change
third world country pakistan pakistan is
a third world country with a new
government whose previous government
destroyed the economy how can a
provincial government a smaller body be
expected to do we're trying to go
everywhere and get to everyone
but these people are not convinced
no one here will sleep hungry tonight
pledging to turn on the electricity and
send more help
a van has arrived with much needed
medicine and there is a fire engine
filled with water that people are using
to fill up all the water in cans and and
vessels that they can to carry into the
flats that they're living in
they're also waiting for cooked food to
be sent to those flats where the people
are and everyone here hopes that there
is enough to go around they also hope
that this is the beginning of promises
being kept
but night came buildings remain dark and
there isn't enough food for everyone
people blame their leaders leaders blame
their circumstances but all agree
international donors need to come here
to witness what is happening
pakistan they say cannot weather this
storm alone
zain basravi al-jazeera sucker sinned
pakistan